by the way just a quick flag um we did
have a hardware failure of one of our SD
cards on the audio recording for this
episode unfortunately so the audio for
this episode is
a little bit worse than the kind of high
quality that we normally go for I still
think the episode is enormously valuable
and I learned so much from the
conversation so I do hope you'll forgive
the slightly choppy audio anyway I hope
you enjoyed the episode when we started
working on eight slave now you know
seven eight years ago we found that the
way that people were talking about sleep
was mostly in the context of illness but
there was no way to describe what it
meant to be healthy in your sleep we
believe that sleep is just like Fitness
it is not just an end you're constantly
working on it it's okay you don't sleep
well tonight what you're about to hear
is an interview between me and this is
the first three-way interview we've done
on the podcast me and Mateo and Alex who
are the husband and wife co-founders of
eight sleep which is the world's first
sleep Fitness company so this
conversation focuses on sort of two main
areas firstly we talk a lot about sleep
Fitness how do we optimize our sleep how
do we make sure we're getting the right
amount of sleep what is the 80 20 of
what we need to know to really maximize
the performance in the realm of sleep
but we also talk about how we maximize
our performance in the realm of diet
like nutrition and exercise as well if
you knew there is one thing that you can
do every single day and will enhance
your body performance is natural and it
will help you live longer than a
healthier life what is that that is late
and so if you want to raise your own
performance bar the number one thing on
Earth you can do sleep and the other
half of the conversation is around
entrepreneurship how he and Alex and
their co-founders built this company to
this valuation of over 500 million
dollars what it's like building a
physical product that's essentially a
mattress that has sensors in it and
circulates water around over 90 of
startups and businesses fail so the
realities there are safer routes to make
money if you want to make money being an
entrepreneur is probably not the easiest
way either you know the number one thing
driving Founders is they don't want to
fail
just a very quick thing before we get
started if you have not yet subscribed
to the podcast either on YouTube or in
your favorite podcast app of choice then
please do it really helps us out a lot
alright so Alex and Mateo thank you so
much for for coming on this is this is
very exciting because I've been if you
guys are the founders of eight sleep
which is now this 500 million dollar
company I've been hearing about you
basically every week on the Tim Ferriss
show and I bought one of the one of the
products a couple weeks ago and it
arrived I think like last week and my my
sister-in-law has been using it for the
last several months and says it's
completely changed their life so really
excited to be talking to you guys and
you're in the UK because you're you're
doing you're sponsoring mercedes's team
for formula one which is just absolutely
insane
um I'd love to get started with like so
eight sleep is apparently the world's
first ever sleep Fitness company so I'd
love to dig into what is sleep Fitness
and kind of the deal with that but
before we do that you guys are
co-founded the company you guys are
married how did you guys meet what was
that all the origin story
we met in Miami actually at the time I
was still living in Italy but I was
starting a business in the US in New
York uh so I was in New York I flew to
Miami for a couple of days of vacation
it was uh Halloween night and we met
actually in a club which is uh not
really as I'm not a big clubbing guy and
she's not a clubbing person but at night
because it was Halloween we both went to
this club our friends they met and then
we were like one next to each other and
we started 32.
it was almost 12 years ago so yeah oh 12
years ago okay that was a while ago yeah
and then there was the following night I
invited her out for dinner because then
I was flying back to Italy so it was bad
for nothing and she agreed to to have
dinner together and then we stayed in
touch or came back to the US and then
it's when we started dating oh wow okay
so you're originally from Italy what
about you what about Europe I'm from
Mexico actually because I was in Miami
just for school oh so you guys were both
kind of in America of just visiting
correct probably yeah so then were you
like long distancing like we did yeah so
I'm from Tijuana at the border
um I was born in California so I did a
year of school in Miami and so we sort
of have this like weird you know
background mix and
um we were in Miami then eventually I
went back to Mexico to finish school he
went back to Italy then we moved to the
US and I graduated so yes I could just
spend like moving all around the world
but the bottom line is was one uh one
year apart and then I moved to New York
to start my previous business Alex grab
calculated and she came to New York with
me okay and that is how everything
started oh excellent so I I understand
that you've got a background as like a
pro pro athlete or something like what's
what that what was happening there was
that in Italy was that in the US uh
there was a in uh in Italy mainly in
Italy and uh yeah I was a tennis player
when I was a teenager I did a bunch of
sports but tennis was the the number one
then I also raced with cars I did some
uh ski races but yeah 90 of my thought
was when I was a teenager was uh being a
tennis player and that is how I got into
recovery performance all that kind of
thing then I studied low so I became a
boring business lawyer I worked for two
archaeologists law firms actually
British law firms aluminum freshers
and then I accepted my first company in
Italy then I sold that so I started
another one in the US and then I started
it what was the first company uh they
were both in solar energy so clean tech
can renewable energy there was a big
booming of clean tech energy
particularly solar in Italy probably the
the only big moment to in in the past 50
years to start a company from scratch in
Italy right and that is how I was able
to shift and switch from being a lawyer
to become an entrepreneur the one
allowed funding okay so pro athlete when
you were young then boring lawyer and
then the entrepreneur in Italy and then
you moved to New York yeah so I sold the
Italian company I moved to the US I
replicated the same business model in
the US we raised some money and then our
pipeline of products got acquired by a a
company owned by Panasonic and then I
started it oh wow okay so by the time
you would exit the second company
presumably you're super rich and don't
need to worry about money at this point
I'm just kind of guessing yeah
I I think we're we're good so then you
never know but yeah yeah what we are
doing now is it's I think outside
I think to help people live a healthier
and longer life if if I look back at the
career one thing I'm really proud of is
the first two companies wearing
cleantech rights and you have the world
to be a better place yeah and now
something in health and so we're helping
human beings to live along of their life
no I love it like well one of the things
I really like about speaking to Founders
is that
and I was reading this in one of these
like CDO coaching books where it's like
usually the first company people start
is because they want to get rich and
then once once they've gotten Rich then
they're like cool I want to get rich and
I have fun and then once they've gotten
rich and had their fun at that point
that the rest of their life is about
actually being service driven and impact
driven yeah and I feel like that was
very much the case for me where I
started off doing like the first
business at University helping people
get into med school
because I enjoy teaching but really I
want to make money because it's like you
know I've got student loans I don't
wanna I don't want to be broke let's try
and make some money and now sort of
seven years down that this YouTube
channel is doing well I feel like my own
internal focus is shifting from how do I
actually try and help people and that
seems to be the arc that a lot of people
go down like genuinely being impact
driven yeah I think probably most of
that comes to like depending on on your
background and I think most in both of
our cases come from families that the
pre-normal and sort of you know the
middle class and they have jobs but like
you don't live in wealth and so a lot of
your first jobs are like yeah you need
to pay back your student loans you have
to make money you need an income maybe
you want to buy a house and so like it's
it's sort of that path and then
eventually you realize maybe you have
more stability than your parents ever
had and you're like okay now I can you
know the Pyramid of Macedonia okay now
the self-actualization actually kicks in
um and I think it's pretty common for
entrepreneurs that are sort of coming
from those those types of backgrounds to
just eventually get rid of that guilt
and be like okay now I can focus on
something else yeah so this is something
I wanted to ask you guys about so you
know Simon sending talks about you start
with Y and all that stuff and I I've
spoken to a lot of young people who want
to start businesses but they all want to
like you know go and go into a
particular career but they're often they
often feel like I don't really know why
I'm doing this I don't know what the
core purpose is behind this other than
to make money and I've always thought
that hey you know to make money is a
reasonable first first goal and then
once you get past that point then you
can worry about the self-actualization
is that is that how you guys think about
it as well or do you think it is
important to have that kind of impact
driven Focus from from day one when
you're starting businesses I think it
can come over time and I think it's
really nice we're actually talking about
that last night for having dinner about
this concept of Legacy right so if you
can reach a point where you really want
to build the brand that is here to stay
and is a global brand and you have this
Legacy where you're helping millions of
people to live a better life right that
is really fulfilling because I think you
will never go through the pain of
Entrepreneurship just because of money I
think money is just a probably an
Evidence of you know this the size of
the results that you deliver but
after a couple of months it's not about
that actually there is Paul Graham who
talks about that and says that the
number one thing driving Founders is uh
they don't want to fail because of now
how would you explain to your mom to
your friends and everyone else and so
avoiding failure is the number one
driver of most Founders yeah yeah
actually and why come here we went
through our community program which is
pretty well known around the world
um now a few years ago and they talked
about the fact that there's easier and
better ways to make money more money
than being an entrepreneur it's true
because probably over 90 of startups and
businesses fail so the realities there
are safer routes to make money
um and if you want to make money being
an entrepreneur is probably not the
easiest way either you know it's very
time consuming so it definitely starts
for some other reason even though there
is that big lofty dream of like you
could become lucky if you actually
strike gold yeah okay so at this point
you've moved to New York to start
company number two in in solar energy
what were you doing at the time yeah so
when I'm engineer I just graduated so I
actually started Communications in
school which is why now I focus on
marketing and the brand for eight sleep
um and then I was just having normal
jobs I graduated from school I'm like
who's going to give me a job in New York
move me there get me started
um so at the time before starting each
sleep I was working at a financial
technology company
um in New York
and so you guys at this point it will
what year are we in when you both moved
to New York that was 2011 yeah 2011 and
then he started eight sleep in 2014.
so for those three years you're working
on solar energy and you've got normal
jobs and then so where did the idea for
eight sleep come from yeah well I would
say in those three years there were also
always like hacking things that's
actually like working together we don't
have like ideas we would like do things
over the weekend so during the yeah
during the weekend we were doing our own
hackathons between the two of us so we
were building staff together what kind
of stuff
websites and we were trying different
kind of business models but it was just
for fun then we started involving Max
with our third co-founder
um and our CTO and he was not the one
who was the the strongest technical
skills and we started now playing on a
couple of different projects with theme
and then a certain part until we came up
with the idea for eight sleep I featured
the max max built the Prototype and then
we organized a pajama party where we
invited friends and Alexandra she
designed the whole presentation and we
put together a quick logo and that is
how everything started because I took
the pajama party one of our friends came
to me and he gave me a 25k check and so
there was no company there was no names
there was nothing and so at that point
we say okay so maybe now we're sitting
corporate yeah and cash the check
um and from there we decided to start
the crowdfunding campaign what were the
dots that connected to lead you to the
idea of
I guess cooling mattress a couple of
different things the the most obvious
one is uh I started wandering a couple
of years before I sleep while on mask is
taking me to Mars but I still spend a
third of my life on a piece of done four
right this technology and everything we
do and then for eight hours a day you go
on this piece of done for me you pretend
to wake up fully refreshed and that was
making no sense to me as an athlete as
an entrepreneur working really long
hours and so I pitched this idea to Max
and we started brainstorming about all
the different types of technologies that
we could bring to your path and then Max
build the Prototype
what was what what else was around at
the time like was was there any other I
guess smart bed stuff there were not
smart beds but I think one of the
interesting things you know when I when
I remember Mateo kind of having this
insight and starting to go through a
process of understanding sleep in the
landscape there were you know Jawbone
was a company that was around doing
wearables there was Fitbit and both of
those companies were starting to track
sleep through werewolves you know at the
beginning they were just on Fitness and
steps and they were going into sleep and
you were using both ran you were sort of
trying to figure out well what what can
I discover about my own sleep and this
in this with this technology there were
apps you could put your phone on the bed
and it would like track through movement
it was like very early on back in yeah
2014 and you started meeting with some
of your friends
um who were like you would have calls
with friends who were athletes back in
Italy there's that friend who like
sailed around the world alone and I
remember that friend connected you with
a doctor who would help these Sailors
train for sleeping in intervals of like
15 minutes because they're alone in the
boat and so you started discovering like
the science of it you're like oh wait
like sleep is actually like it's pretty
complex and like there's all these
things that have been learned around
sleep and so like that is how the rabbit
hole really started to understand that
technology could influence some
important factors of sleep and the the
foundation of it and it's really is
still what we did today is saying well
the first thing is we believe it ain't
sleep and now as we did back then that
data is very important you can't improve
what you don't measure so what is the
most seamless way in which we can
measure and that was sort of seeing well
wearables were not really cutting it for
us and like the phones were not really
accurate and that's where Max our
co-founder and TP also what we can put
sensors in the bed but then from there
all of those conversations with the
scientists that knew more than us uh
guided us to say well with that data
there's a lot of personalization you can
do the environment and that's how you
unlock the optimization of sleep nice
okay so a couple of questions before we
dive into like the the technology
firstly it's a high performers athletes
and stuff like how obsessed are they
with tracking things and like what what
is that world like you know recovery and
performance and stuff yeah so this is
almost a gap because they are obsessed
with sleep and performance but at the
end of the day they don't track much and
they don't even know much about what you
can to actually improve your sleep like
camera regulation so one of the most
surprising things for me now that we
work with some of the best athletes in
the world is really this Gap where the
camera regulation is the big elephant in
the room if you want to improve your
sleep maybe what they know is just oh I
should sleep at 78 degrees my room my
bedroom should be at 78 degree which is
not even right because if the
temperature should change during the
night right so 178 degree could be right
for one hour two hours of the whole
night but the rest of the time you need
a different temperature
um and sometimes they don't track
themselves right even on a daily basis
with an Apple Watch or maybe they just
track themselves while they are
exercising rather than that they don't
track themselves too much actually a big
surprise I would say when we go to
dinner with athletes is food yeah
because I'm a kind of bio-acourage
meaning I like to play with all that
stuff usually I have a CGM like
everything right and so I'm on a keto
diet I fast I I do all these kind of
things to optimize my performance and
most of these times I remember we went
with a really famous swimmer and we were
asking him okay what do you eat now the
night before you lean bake things like
that and we were surprised about the
fact that he was joking about eating a
pizza the night before just because
that's what he liked and he was going
for that and this is
you know you're like okay all right
you're really talented because if you
could win without paying attention to
nutrition
um at least that yeah just a quick
message from one of our sponsors and
we'll get right back to the episode and
this episode is very kindly brought to
you by Heights Heights is a brain care
smart supplement it is two capsules that
you take every day I've been taking it
for the last 12 months and it contains
over 20 evidence-based micronutrients
that you need to keep your brain and
body healthy like I said I've been
taking Heights every day for the last 12
months and through that I've actually
become friends with the founder Dan who
we actually had on season one of this
podcast and this season we also have an
interview with neuroscientist and
psychiatrist Tara swart who is the chief
science officer at Heights as well and
one of the things I love about Heights
is the fact that every single thing they
do is very evidence-based over on their
blog on their website they've got tons
of Articles along with links to all of
the different papers that they've cited
that show all the benefits of the
various micronutrients that they've got
in these two little capsules and the
best thing about taking these is that
it's just two little capsules every
morning so you don't have to deal with
green sludge or any other kind of
faffrey it's just literally taking two
pills it's super easy to sign up you
just go on the website but you put in
your address and they send you either a
monthly or a quarterly subscription I
sign up to the quarterly one myself
because a it's cheaper and B I'd have to
take fewer deliveries and if you use the
coupon code Ali 15 at checkout that will
give you 15 off the already discounted
price of the quarterly subscription so
you can try out Heights to your heart's
content so thank you so much Heights for
sponsoring this episode and for helping
improve my own brain care for normal
people like what sort of
gains do you get in terms of I I guess a
lot of people listening to this might be
thinking uh you know I sleep well enough
I eat well enough I'm not overweight
like
be beyond the basics how needle moving
is it to start optimizing things and
like you know doing the continuous
glucose monitoring and the ice paths and
like all the states like are we are we
talking kind of final percentage point
optimizations or is it actually
surprisingly like bigger than that no it
could be pretty big maybe I'll just give
like a bit in the background where like
people say we hear very often it's like
oh I sleep well right and what you
realize and like the stats show you is
like really at least a third of the
world totally sleep deprived and you
often hear people say like well I sleep
six hours or something because I think
four hours but it becomes a normal
people think that the way they feel is
normal because you're sort of like used
to it my body is amazing has this
capacity to adapt but Mattel always
talks about the fact that like if you
just try for a week sleeping one hour
longer
um especially if you are sleep deprived
you'll see how much better you can feel
and all your potential that would be
unlocked that's my test right to people
and sometimes even when people say I
need a vacation I just say no you just
need to sleep one hour longer every
single day because if you think over a
week seven hours of sleep you're getting
one night of sleep right yeah and so
just try that because if you want need a
vacation but you cannot go on vacation
sleep one hour long every day for seven
days then come back to me and I'll give
you 100 bucks if you don't feel better
all right okay that's a good test but
going back to your question I think it
depends meaning sleep sleeping the right
amount of hours and in the proper way
it's gonna be
disruptive in a positive sense for how
you feel then the second biggest one is
definitely Fitness right working out is
going to make a massive uh difference in
how you feel and also in how you eat
right because if you train in the
morning it's uh unlikely that you will
create junk food you know it's it's
almost like a sequence and you will
start taking care of yourself more and
more and then I would say in terms of
nutrition there are a couple of things
that are the 80 20 right okay avoid this
or just I don't know try to skip one of
the meals and just eat within an eight
hours window and then you can take it to
the next level where you are on a keto
you just eat once per day but that I
think is the last one two percent okay
great so when it comes to sleep let's
say for normal people what is the 80 20
of what we can do to have to improve it
consistency forgot to bad at the same
time wake up at the same time sleep
seven to nine hours take care of your
temperature so 10 more regulation
because these three things
yeah eighty percent probably 90 percent
there is that so what I've I've read why
we sleep and I've read like some
rebuttal online about like oh why we
take this [ __ ] because of all these
things and there seems to be a lot of
like
um um controversy in the literature
around like seven hours eight hours nine
hours six hours like what's the kind of
normal person take away from from this
so the interesting thing and that is
also part of the reason why we are
called a sleep because I don't believe
you need eight hours of sleep and this
is how everything started so before I
eat sleep I started looking into okay
can I sleep last so how many people work
hard sometimes that's why I wanted to
work more and work out more and I
discovered that the original reason why
we say that there should be eight hours
it is just an average and so everyone is
different the bottom line is you need a
certain amount of deep sleep and a
certain amount of RAM and a paid sleep
we believe we will compress your sleep
so in the future you will be able to
sleep only six hours and get more rest
then when you were sleeping eight hours
then going back to your question is in
general an approximation is that you
need between seven and nine hours to get
that amount of the background everyone
is different in our case we tend to see
but at least eight hours and a half
every single night at the end of the day
you need to do what it you know makes
you feel good but the important thing is
that you don't oversleep for example
during the weekends a lot of people say
okay you know during the week I go to
sleep at 10 I wake up at six but then
during the weekend I try to recover and
I sleep until 10 a.m that's wrong
because substantially you're jet lagging
yourself because it's not that your body
knows that it's the weekend it says why
now you're waking up three hours later
maybe you are on a different in a
different time yeah and it's like that
consistency will train your body to wake
up naturally at that time and you will
feel more refreshed when you wake up so
what why is that
I you have a biological clock and you
have your own circadian cycle and that
is how your body operates right so this
internal uh clock is setting all your
new physiological needs including sleep
and so you just want to be as consistent
as possible so your body goes into a
sort of autopilot and knows that I need
to feel asleep at this time and I need
to wake up naturally at this time so
what time do you guys sleep and wake up
what's that yeah we got to bed around 10
10 30 and we wake up anywhere between
six six thirty seven at least okay so
one of the one of the issues that I have
and I'm sure a lot of our listeners will
be feeling the same as that
you know I have I would have an
intention but oh I'd love to go to bed
by 10 30. but you know
I might be watching something or I might
be on my phone or I might have some
friends over or dinner might be going on
late and I'm always thinking huh how
important is it really that I sleep at
10 30 today uh like how how do you guys
do that consistently with a busy and
social lifestyle and how much leeway do
you give yourselves to not do that yeah
so we are pretty regimented on that I
would say uh so first of all I think we
are like in the US you can have dinner
social dinners quite early so you can't
have the United States very in Italy
would never have it I think I end up
going nine yeah in Pakistan it's like 11
p.m yeah
so we go for if we have a social dinner
we try to set it early let's say six six
thirty and then we can be home by 8 30
and start decompressing uh but it's
really important because if you care
about your performance the following day
it's really important that we wake up at
6 30 7 6 whatever that we feel energized
so then we can work out and then kick
off to be in the proper way so almost
you should think of sleep like the the
most
enhancement the strongest enhancement
drug on Earth if you if you will right
and I think there is much worker in the
book that you were mentioning that talks
about that right if you knew there is
one thing that you can do every single
day and will enhance your body
performance is natural and it will help
you live longer than a healthier life
what is that that is late and so if you
want to raise your own performance power
the number one thing on Earth you can do
sleep
sick and it's free yeah yeah that's so
good like everything is consequential
meaning if you want to work out
right so first of all I don't know if
you know it but you will you will die
sooner from sleep deprivation than from
uh from food right okay hopefully none
of them is going to happen but the other
important thing is there are three
pillars in half right one is lead one is
a fitness and the other is nutrition but
the foundational piece is lip if you
don't sleep you're not gonna work out
today you feel too tired you're unable
to perform you will start craving junk
food and probably you will start eating
carbs and everything else right so the
foundational part is sleep sleep well
seven to nine hours you wake up feeling
great and fresh that will drive you to
work out and eat properly I'm
um should you uh so if you know you've
got your sleep well okay now I'll
rephrase that
some days I wake up feeling refreshing
I'm like yeah and a lot of other days
I'm like
if you have the sleep thing dialed in do
you always wake up feeling like yeah is
that is that like the aim or is it is it
normal to feel tired when you when you
wake up I don't think it's always the
same but the part of the Mattel was
mentioning before it really is true when
you become very consistent that's why
consistency is is such an important
factor like that's where you can start
with improving your sleep you will wake
up more naturally and just the fact that
your body wakes up on its own and that's
because of that circading clock you will
feel better the probabilities that you
will feel maybe not Ultra energize every
morning but just wake up on your own or
much higher when you stay consistent and
that already makes a difference in the
perception you have of how you feel when
you wake up yeah yeah I've I've
definitely found like any time I read a
Sleep Book or have a conversation with
someone who's into sleep then I'm like
super consistent for the next five days
or whatever and I'm currently on a
consistent thing where every morning I
wake up at half seven the last night I
had a slightly later night and I set the
alarm for half past day I'll just look
at the half of seven anyway I actually
feel awake cool let's just get out of
bed and it was and it's it's almost been
nice these last several days like
turning off my alarm when it's like
iPhone's like oh it looks like you're
awake do you want to yeah
and then there is another three oh yeah
I was recently interviewed by fortune
and I spoke about that that is the
nahuchino do you know the nappuccino no
it wasn't actually so an apple chain is
these let's say you were happy you don't
feel great you can try to take a nap
during the day but the best thing you
should do is you should drink a coffee
before the nap the reason is the coffee
will kick in 30 minutes later the nap
should be no longer than 30 minutes
usually they're recommended amount of
time is 20. and so you have an espresso
you try to take the nap by the time you
wake up from the nap the coffee will
kick in and you will feel like a super
Superman and you guys take naps yes when
we can yes I mean I think it's what you
were mentioning was like you know your
social life and work it happens so like
you can't maybe be taking notes every
day especially if you're going into an
office physically
um but samples were like we're in London
we don't live here when you're
deadlocked right like what is the right
way to do it well you want to stay
consistent when you wake up wake up
early in the morning don't try to
oversleep but then maybe you'll need a
nap later in the day we take the nap and
then do the nappacino thing you wake up
and then you keep going and a lot of
athletes MBA actually it's like a lot of
athletes that play at the night they try
to take a nap in the afternoon to
undercover because it's a matter of
adenosine right so the the map will help
you to reduce the amount of adenosine in
your brain and you will feel more
energized and refreshed
and like this okay so this is a very
specific question of this but anytime
I've tried to take a nap I'm always like
all right cool 20 minutes 30 minutes
and then it takes me like 15 minutes to
even fall asleep and then I'm like it
was not even worth it like do you guys
fall asleep immediately when you no I
mean your mind is probably erasing like
nine so I struggled with that so first
you start learning yeah probably it's
gonna take me 15 minutes I have to fall
asleep but the key thing is usually you
don't need to and actually you don't
want to fall into deep sleep or rent so
you want the very light sleep that is
just gonna relax your brain and reduce
the amount of adenosine and so sometimes
yeah you feel bad like oh I didn't
really fall asleep but that is already
helpful for your brain yeah there's a
type of sort of like the Sleep Dr Andrew
talks a lot about like the non-sleep
deep rest and so you can enter that sort
of like this like kind of meditative
State and where like your brain is
stressing and maybe you didn't fall
fully asleep like it's still valuable
for your brain to just really try to try
to fall asleep and give it that moment
of rest yeah if anything is just a
relaxation thing even if you don't fall
asleep just a quick little break before
we get right back to the episode and
that's to let you know that this episode
is very kindly brought to you by short
form short form is the world's best
service for summaries of books but it's
more than just book summaries what short
form does is it basically creates a sort
of study guide for tons and tons of
different non-fiction books from all
sorts of genres from self-help and
personal development to money and
history and philosophy it's just got
loads of really interesting books and
they summarize them firstly with a cool
one-page summary but then they also have
chapter by chapter outlines of each book
and in between the chapter summaries
they also have kind of interactive
exercise sections where you can take the
insights from the book and actually
apply them to your life and the other
cool thing about short form is that if
for example an author says something
that is a little bit dodgy or that has
been debunked or kind of disagreed with
with another author then the short form
team will write a note saying that hey
you know this person said this thing
about this topic but actually that has
been debunked by this other person and
they'll bring in another source and so
it's not just a way of getting summaries
of books it's also a way of expanding
your understanding of the genre as a
whole for example One summary I read
recently was the minimalist entrepreneur
by sahil Lavinia who is the founder of
gumroad now I read the book it's self a
year ago or so when it came out but I
found it super helpful to look at the
short form summary to revisit some of
the ideas in the book and this kind of
tends to be how I use short form either
I use it as a way of deciding whether I
want to read a book if it's new to me or
I use it as a way of revisiting ideas
from books I've already read so if any
of that stands up your street and you
too would like to try out the world's
best service for summarizing books then
head over to shortform.com forward slash
Deep dive and firstly that will give you
a completely free five-day trial where
you can try it out and see if you like
it and it will also give you 20 off the
annual premium subscription which is the
thing that I personally subscribe to so
thank you so much short form for
sponsoring this episode Okay so we've
talked about seven to nine hours we've
talked about consistency can you talk me
more about thermoregulation what do we
mean by that yeah so the other big
elephant in the room to really improve
your sleep how much you have to
disorders is temperature and so your
body temperature changes during the
night and as soon as you fall asleep
your body temperature drops and then a
couple of hours before the time you want
to wake up your body temperature will
rise which if you think it does the same
thing of the sun right so 90 gets colder
and colder and then a couple of hours
before the sunrise it starts warming up
and the Sun comes out and it's warmer
right so your body does the same exact
thing so what we do at day sleep is we
didn't reinvent the wheel we just help
your body to actually do in the proper
way what it's supposed to do and so your
med will have a certain temperature by
the time you go to bed it could be hot
or cold and we're between 55 and 110
degrees each side of the bed can have a
different temperature so I've got it in
Celsius
ranges between 10 and 35 ish something
like that so really cold to really warm
it's unlikely you go to this next text
yeah
um but the bottom line is you you're
getting bad is a certain temperature
that you like as soon as you fall asleep
the temperature will drop
um because what you want in the first
part of the night is a colder
temperature because in the first part of
the 90 you tend to get more deep sleep
in the second part of the night when you
said you tend to get more RAM you want
the warmer temperatures called Almost
terminal neutrality and the reason is
when you are in Ram your brain
deactivates a lot of controls in Grammys
when you're dreaming right and so you
run you're not moving at all yeah
because the body wants to protect itself
because you're dreaming yeah right and
one of the things that deactivates is
temperature control and so you want to
be in this neutral thermal neutral
environment so your body doesn't think
that you could die during okay
what's going on but the bottom line is
based on the defensive stages you need
different temperatures and that is what
we provide the results are that you get
up to 34 more deep sleep you get up to
32 percent more sleep quality and you
get up to 19 percent better recovery so
pretty meaningful numbers that's pretty
sick um okay so the is is there like an
Optimum temperature for people that
don't have a night's sleep like the
reality is no there is an approximation
which is what usually you know you hear
saying oh you should sleep at 68 70
degrees which is what 18 19 yeah but the
reality is that's wrong because again
your body temperature changes your sleep
cycle is changing yeah and so
temperatures should adjust accordingly
okay
um okay so we talked about sleep
um what is it what's the 80 20 of
um exercise and nutrition as well yeah
for example 5 is heat uh so high
intensity intervals training and
strength training so with heat what you
want to do is you want to spike your
heart rate and you want to let it drop
you want to do this three to five times
a week at least 20 minutes each time is
what it will be up to the other big
thing is dry straining all right
um and so you should do that a couple of
times a week as well for from Dead
Leaves to chest training that will help
hormones like testosterone and other
things and both of them they will help
you the responsive medical studies that
they will help you live a longer and
healthier life because you are taking
care of your cardiovascular system and
you're also making sure that all your
muscles are strong okay working out in
the morning versus the evening versus
the afternoon any consensus on that
so on that you can be flexible whatever
works best for you my recommendation is
don't work out three hours before going
to bed otherwise you will accelerate
your heart rate and it will be harder to
cause it so do you have to work out in
the morning or what's your yeah it's the
best yeah but I think one of the
interesting things that I talk a lot
about because he experienced a lot with
all these things and then he ends up
driving me into it is that the
difference is just biologically amongst
you know like even male female bodies
and like our hormones and so even the
example of working out a lot of the
things now that people talk about in in
the in the health space is that
personalization for women throughout the
month because as we go through different
hormone levels throughout our monthly
Cycles there is uh different recommended
ways to work out for your body because
your body may need to utilize the energy
for different things throughout the
month especially while you have your
actual like menstruation during the
month right so it gets really
fascinating that it's becoming more and
more towards personalization which is
the same thing we folks who need sleep
with with sleep the personal stations
are leaking everyone needs a different
temperature everyone has different needs
throughout every day and every day of
their life that's the same for working
out and nutrition is another big big one
um when we've used
um use complex monitors and we've tested
it it's just so incredible that we have
such different response to foods but at
the end of the day when you're cooking
in a household you're cooking the same
meal for both people right and so how do
you start understanding that actually
diets are not like a blanket that's all
but people will actually have very
different needs and hormones play a big
role into that and in the case of women
hormones actually change on a daily
basis yeah so it sounds like the a lot
of the a lot of the sort of
approximations like the whole 90 degree
sleep the whole you know the way we
exercise the way we eat
a lot of it is just sort of broad brush
stroke things that people can decide I
suppose it
you know some exercises better than no
exercise but if you're going to optimize
a bit more then okay let's not do it
three hours before bed and there's
always more levels you could go down if
you really wanted to right that's like
you know with skincare as well there's
like three main things and everything
else is sort of our last five five ten
percent yeah so Okay so we've talked
about exercise
um finally nutrition what's 80 20 before
we dive into the the Sleep Tech stuff so
day 20 is about sugar right you don't
want sugar it will create a group of
spikes the sugars can be known the
regular sugar that we all know but it
also comes through carbs
um so that is the number one thing that
you should try to avoid then if you want
to take it to the next level there is
what is called fasting right and you
could do what is called the 16 8 so try
not to eat for 16 hours or you could
even avoid eating the whole day you just
have one meal a day but that to me is
the extreme I do that but I don't think
it's really needed the best thing is if
you could just have a 16 hours window
without eating the reason is digestion
has been consuming in terms of energy
for your body then you want to leave
your body alone for 16 hours so it can
be focused on repairing cells instead of
the digestion and that should in theory
help you to avoid cancer over
time Mediterranean diet is the other big
thing that is recommended the other
thing you need to pay attention is
alcohol to this point of medical
evidence that Alpha will have a very
negative impact on user quality so you
could have a drop of even 20 percent in
terms of HIV and Deep Sleep
Quality if you have alcohol at night and
so usually you should stop a drink in
three to five hours before going to bed
or at least you should limit the amount
of alcohol that you think nice okay yeah
I'm I I started doing 69 like last week
which uh so yeah doing a you know I
think feeding window is like 12 12 to 8.
I I yeah I think I think your tip about
just the the social dinners at 6 PM is
just such a game changer because in my
mind dinner equals 8 PM I just took
completely no reason for that yeah
because then by the time you order it's
9 pm and then it's like obviously gonna
hang out there until 11 p.m like you go
to sleep on me now
I'll call and and so you you just have
to drink and then you go to bed and then
you wake up and you already be happy
yeah so do you do you guys um train when
fasted as well in the morning yes okay
so any pre-workouts caffeine freaking
any of that the caffeine yes there are
some debates about that I think
picarattia and also Kim Ferris they talk
about that some people like to eat
something popular proteins before
training some people do it immediately
after which should still be fine for
your muscles in my case because I fast
all day I never eat but actually I think
it would be better if you if I remember
correctly from picarattia that you can
take some proteins within a couple of
hours after three
nice so who talked about the age 20
staff that most people can can do the
thing the actual thing that I will take
away from this is the social events 6
p.m because that I think that is the
same one just completely changes okay
um okay so well I would say eat that 6
p.m together if you can't sleep seven to
nine hours terrain two three times a
week just be active right and try to go
for a Mediterranean diet that this is
the simplest way that is not too
cumbersome amazing okay so what is sleep
Fitness then
so the bachelor in sleep Fitness is that
when we started working on eight slave
now you know seven eight years ago we
found that the way that just in general
the media and people were talking about
sleep was mostly in the context of
illness so you would hear a lot about
sleep deprivation and insomnacy Batman
like all the bad things yeah but there
was no way to describe what it meant to
be healthy in your sleep and what we
realized is like if you don't have the
language to say I'm healthy in my sleep
then what are people aspiring to how are
they measuring it right how we're
talking about it and that's how the
concept of sleep Fitness came about why
sleep Fitness because we believe that
sleep is just like Fitness it is it is
not just an end you're constantly
working on it it's okay you don't sleep
well tonight
um but you're just you know going back
just like when you go back to working on
you go back to the gym something you
need to be be optimizing you need to be
actually prioritizing in your life you
can be measuring and so it follows a
very similar pattern to your physical
fitness so we came up with this word and
it was a concept that we thought
describes it really well and we made it
a key part of our business and our brand
and ultimately describes that state of
being healthy in your sleep and the
energy that you get from it
that is the same mindset of going to the
gym right you need to put the effort you
need to put the effort to go to sleep at
10 10 30 even if there are other things
that you might want to do because it
will make you feel great it's like going
to the gym yeah and if you have like one
or two nights where it's like you're
traveling or what then it's like yeah
for X days because you didn't have the
time but you want that mindset where do
you think matters to me it matters for
my health it matters for my performance
so I'm gonna go to bed now because
tomorrow I need to be an IIT performance
okay so we're 2014 you guys have come up
with the idea of kind of connecting
these dots of like okay why are we
sleeping on a random dumb piece of foam
and your friend Max realizes we can put
sensors in the bed like
what is what are the sensors doing yeah
so so essentially the device is becoming
a clinical grade device right we just
reach 99 accuracy at tracking your heart
rate compared to a medical grade device
in EKG right which if you think is
pretty honestly dependently from the
fact that one of the founders but it's
pretty shocking right so you're bad
Without You winning anything charging
anything you go to bed in this bed now
is able to track your heart rate it's
the same degree and level of accuracy of
a medical grid device yeah right so if
you just think from a technological
standpoint it's pretty amazing so how
does that compare to Apple watch or our
ring you know these other wearably type
things that allegedly claim to do the
same yeah so there are almost all these
devices reaching almost the same level
of accuracy the key difference with our
devices you don't need to wear anything
you don't need to charge anything
right
when you charge it not too bad as you
did for the rest of your life and when
you wake up if you wanted you can see
all the stats about your cardiovascular
health right and this is just the
beginning the next algorithm we're gonna
release will be about respiration and
our respiratory rate has 99 percent
accuracy as well which means we'll be
able to see things like snoring and
sleep apnea without you wearing anything
again you just go to bed the other key
difference between a sleep and most of
the wearables is that the data for us is
not the end point it's just the
beginning based on the data then we take
action for you right so based on your
sleep stages we change the temperature
of the bed in the future we'll take
certain actions if you're snoring or if
you have sleep apnea to reduce the
snorling in this ecotnia and so we
really use data as the Step Zero to then
do the work for you while you are
unconscious and improve your performance
why should we care about what is our
heart rate during sleep like what's
what's going on there yeah so first and
the most basic thing is a couple of days
before you get sick you have fever your
heart rate and rest will change and will
go up and so nowadays I'm able to
predict when I will be sick uh my team
knew that I was getting covered before I
had coffee because my Biometrics started
changing respiration after the other
important thing is cardiovascular health
so heart rate and heart rate variability
are a proxy for how rested you are you
are and how stressed you are right and
so for example if you stop training or
going to the gym for a couple of months
your heart rate the rest will probably
go up right because you are not training
your your
heart on the other side there is this
Methodist called heart rate viability I
don't know if you have ever heard of
that but it's substantially a metric
that tracks the the space in between the
heartbeats and you want the space to
change all the times because it means
that your heart rate is more reactive
things like a boxer right when the boxes
is really fresh the boxer is moving and
adjusting to every little tiny details
as you as the boxer get the tire it
starts becoming in a you know at this
lower Pace more Casa so this proxy is
very indicative of how rested you are so
to give you an idea is you let's say you
have a certain number as as Baseline
call it 60. if tomorrow you go and you
run another film the following day this
number will go down because your heart
rate is tired right well instead if you
rest for a couple of days this number
will go up ah okay can you look at heart
rate variability on like yeah yeah you
can it has become a really popular
metric because it is a proxy product and
so athletes have used it for a long time
now all these consumer devices use it as
well and what we do is obviously you
don't have to wear anything it's
tracking it for you as well yeah now the
reason why all of these things exist is
first because if you go to a Sleep
Clinic
um you would be using these same metrics
to do that reported Sleep Clinic so we
sort of like took the Sleep Clinic and
just like brought it home and the only
thing we're missing is those brain waves
right but like we are taking the same
metrics and saying well the same things
you would discover at a clinic that you
probably you know at least in the United
States will pay a lot of money for and
have to find Insurance to pay for you do
it at home you do it every night
um and then on top of that as much as
describing you also get this benefit
that not only do you get all of the
Sleep staging classification and Sleep
Quality but you are getting that same
metric that you get on a wearable
without the wearable heart rate and
breast respiratory rate heart
variability which like he mentioned
there's the disease certified the
intervention of like one man getting
sick am I getting stressed we also see
you know women during pregnancy like
their heart rates change um carrying
like two hard pigs in your body your
body is more and sort of doing extra
work but you can also see the trends
over time like we have a lot of our
members who they tend to reach out to my
toe personally through DM him on Twitter
and say hey
um I either like was getting sick I was
able to notice it on my on my eight
sleep pod because I've been sitting on
for so long so you have trended data
that maybe before the wearable era
before the eight sleep product type era
you would only get it when you were
going to the doctor right you go to the
doctor they would take all your
Biometrics now you have them at home a
few weeks ago we saved the first life uh
so I personally reach out to me and he'd
say look uh I was not feeling great I
checked my data on a sleep I saw that
the Biometrics were all over the place
compared to my usual Baseline I went
straight to ER and they found an issue I
had a surgery and that's it in my life
in my life a cardio surgery
so that is an example and then other
people wrote me because we helped them
with covet both by you know measuring
the Biometrics and through temperature
um we see people with Cancers uh using
our product that both because of
temperature because they have hot
flashes and also because we measure the
Biometrics women in menopause at the end
of the day what you will see happening
in the next
three to five years is medical devices
and consumer devices are merging right
Apple watch is not competing with Rolex
this is not really a watch you have a
poster and all the time but at the end
of the day it's a medical device to
continuously track your health
our device does the same but the
advantage is you use it every single day
because you go to bed every single day
right and what you will be able to build
is you are you're building a database of
your health that you will be able to
share with your doctor so the doctor
will have a snapshot immediately of
anything that is happening in your body
knowing what the Baseline is and you
will also know how you're aging because
your heart rate today is different from
your heart rate in three years from now
and 10 years from now and we'll be able
to let you know how you're doing
compared to other peers and then machine
learning in AI will be able to predict
the likelihood you develop a certain
type of disease
all this is coming the step there is
always to collect the data in an
accurate way which is happening across
the board and then is when technology
will really deliver the next value yeah
think of computers in the 70s when they
were not connected to the internet
people's area why do I need these how
can this be helpful
but then as once that everyone in the
world started having a computer and then
there was the internet and then the
mobile Innovation and now everyone has a
phone in the hands which is a computer
nothing right here so like
even when I was uh when I was working as
a doctor there was a lot of talk around
personalized pharmacology and I
personalized medication because it's
just a bit weird that we take the same
dose for occasionally for a drug that's
like if you want between 30 kg and 150
kg take this dose that's such a huge
range and people are like yeah it's at
some point we're going to be able to
have more personal life therapies and I
guess this is just that except for all
of your health data correct it would be
like uh getting a physical exam every
single night you know when they in the
past uh to our past they used to say oh
you should go to the doctor once a year
to do you know the basic exams the thing
is gonna happen every single night and
the data will can be compared across
millions of people at the same time so
medicine will just move
faster right we have an Advisory board
with some of the best sleep professors
in the world people from Harvard stand
for Japan Colombia and the reason why
they joined the board is in one night we
collect more data than what they have
seen in their whole career
yeah a friend of mine at University is
also a doctor was having some issues
with sleeping I was like oh yeah to
sleep like 11 hours a night doesn't work
and so she did this kind of Sleep Clinic
study thing at like one of the local
hospitals and it was such a huge like
song and dance she had to take like
three days off it was like a whole thing
they could only do like two patients at
a time ridiculously expensive obviously
the NHS pay for it so she didn't have to
pay and then she had to like she was Ill
one of the day so she had to cancel the
appointment and we were just thinking my
God like how much did it cost the system
to cancel that appointment and all they
were doing was cameras and heart rate
and a good thing on ahead and like that
would be a place yeah but let me tell
you also this there is you know what you
sleep apnea right so it's this
difficulty to breathe during the night
and this is gonna impact Your Sleep
Quality and can I also have a negative
impact on your brain and definitely it
will make sure that you don't feel good
when you wake up because you didn't have
proper sleep yeah so there are uh a
billion people in the world with sleep
happy
do you want to know how many a billion
yeah
I don't know they have 90 okay and the
reason is simple a lot of people they
guess they have it because usually it's
the partner noticing it but they don't
want to go through the same experience
of your friend they don't want to go to
the doctor get the recommendation and
all the prescription for a sleep study
go in a hospital sleep there cover with
sensors no one wants to do that and so
they say you know what yeah maybe it has
a puppy and maybe not but who cares
let's move on and 90 of people with
sleep apnea gain a billion people don't
know
yeah
um why is sleep happening at that
sleep apnea is bad because substantially
oxygen is not properly circulating in
your body it doesn't get to your brain
usually you know when you have sleep
apnea you tend to do that right right
there's some snoring yeah it's like
snoring 2.0 yeah but to a point where
oxygen doesn't get to the brain and this
is gonna impact on your your whole sleep
staging and so you're not going to get
the proper amount of deep sleep and
you're not going to get the appropriate
amount of rain even if you sleep 11
hours
you have the Sleep Quality of someone
who's like a couple of hours yeah and
it's it degenerates right so it is a
disease and a condition that like will
just get worse over time will get worse
with aging it is highly correlated with
being overweight or obese but it's just
not because of that right so like there
are also people who may be like good
with our weight but they have it
um and so it's really hard to catch like
it's such like sort of like a silent
killer yeah
yeah
um one critique I've heard of this whole
like data defying all of our health data
is similar to what some people say
around blood tests so the in the U.S
there seems to be a culture of like see
your doctor every year and get a
biomarkers etc etc in the UK it's a bit
more like uh don't don't see your doctor
unless you have a problem and then
you'll do a blood test because what's
the point of doing a blood test every
like maybe you'll catch an incidental
thing which is like wasn't affecting
your life anyway what's the point of
doing an MRI every year because a lot of
the incidental tumors that you might
find will never cause a problem and so
you're wasting a lot of healthcare
resources in doing these pointless tests
and you're making people feel anxious
about their health because now they have
all the data all the time how do you
guys deal with that well before you go
inside now you have very strong I'd say
I would pay attention to who is saying
that right like obviously depending on
the health system in every country the
recognition will be different but like
when it is the government who needs to
provide all these services and that's
based on your taxation and all that well
that they're going to try to keep you
away from going into the system because
it costs money but the reality is you
care about your body and so who should
you be listening to and what wouldn't it
be better if you knew even if that tumor
or that you know cyst or that muscular
uh issue what's there would you prefer
to know that not know that something is
happening to you
I think the answer to me is I don't know
how many people know that but
um if you have pancreatic cancer and you
detect it early you have 90 chances to
leave if you detect it late you have 90
chances to die
and so assuming you want to keep living
your life you want to spend time with
your loved ones and knowing what's
happening in your body and optimizing
your health I just think it's in the
best interest of all of us
this will help you not just to extend
your lifespan but to extend your health
span right my grandma I think she dies
in the 90s and I mean when when she was
90 years old in 1995 but she spent the
last 20 years of her life really sitting
on a chair she had a neat tooth it was
one night that she this happened right
so she had a an arterial problem and
since then she couldn't move in our part
of her body that could have been avoided
and she could have lived you know 20
years of her life being Dynamic and
spending that time with her friend
children
yeah yeah I a few a few years ago I I
discovered just the world of anti-aging
and Longevity and stuff and yeah before
then I just hadn't considered it I I
always just thought oh you know I guess
I guess we die what else and then I was
I started reading the stuff I was like
oh my god of course we want to live a
longer and healthier like why wouldn't
you like because sometimes people tell
me oh I don't want to leave long they're
fine but do you want to enjoy your life
after the last day yeah right because I
don't think you want to see it on a
chair in front of the TV for 20 years of
your life right from 65 or 70 to 90.
right so this is why this matters then
you don't have to look at the metrics
every single day some people even some
customers few of them but uh say oh I I
feel anxious with the dip and that is an
advantage of our product because you
don't see it you don't wear it yeah
right and so the link is there whenever
that is needed share it with your doctor
and the doctor will be able to take
better actions even if you go for you
know the more UK approach the you are
describing word oh look I don't want to
know anything until when I need to have
a problem that day having the Baseline
of your data for the past 20 years will
become relevant and so let these devices
do their job in the background even if
you don't open the app but that day when
something happened because it will
happen then your doctor you will be able
to provide your doctor more information
to help you live a longer and healthier
one yeah yeah it's it's amazing just how
often we used to have this issue with
with patients that would come in have
some like chest pain or something you do
an ECG or EKG and you would see
something weird like as a bit of
estimation there like I'm not really
sure and you're like okay what's their
Baseline I don't know it's like have
they ever had an ECG before maybe but
like maybe it was a different hospital
systems don't talk to each other they've
probably never had one before I'm like
oh [ __ ] okay well how bad is this thing
okay we should probably just keep him in
overnight for the next five days anyway
put them on cardiac monitoring just in
case
this is
yeah
um yeah no I'm I'm massively bullish on
knowing the health data for myself
because like yes if I was trying to run
a government-funded healthcare system
I wouldn't want to do it for all 70
million people in the UK because I
thought a lot of money and maybe the ROI
if that's not great but as an individual
I'm sure you know I'm gonna I'm gonna do
whatever I can to to kind of maximize
this
um okay so heart rate heart rate
variability respiratory rate
presumably the sensors in the mattress
are looking at those things and figuring
out what stage of sleep you're in is
that fair to say yeah together with
movement and temperature movement and
temperature okay so for someone who's
who doesn't know much about space like
what are the different stages of sleep
and what are like how how do you know
that we're in set stages of sleep yeah
so I always think there is a medical
explanation where I could be more
technical yeah
and and probably not the most helpful
but the bottom line is you have what is
called light sleep this is the teacher
will give to government grammar okay so
you have the light sleep and then you
have deep and then you have right okay
right what you really care about is the
amount of deep and the amount of rent
okay both in terms of time like an hour
plus whatever depends on how much how
long you sleep and then it's also
percentage right so for me if I explain
example specifically anything below 18
deep sleep assuming I sleep eight hours
I I will wake up feeling terrible
between 18 and 21 I feel pretty good and
about 21 I'm a superhero and you figure
that out for yourself yeah by looking at
your stats being like what do I feel so
good today and it's like oh [ __ ] I have
20 25 exactly okay usually the range
recommended is anywhere between 15 and
25 okay and then it can be that's right
deep sleep so what percentage of your
sleep time you are in deep sleep mode
okay anywhere between if a commanded is
anywhere between 15 and 25 okay uh and
then the ram is very similar in terms of
ranges usually slightly higher so more
in the 20 to 25 but it could go as low
as 15. then things change because for
example if you're a sleep deprived let's
say that tonight you don't sleep for
whatever reason because you're in the
hospital you can't sleep and tomorrow
you finally sleep the first thing that
your body will prioritize is deep sleep
okay and so tomorrow night you will get
way more deep sleep than Ram okay deep
sleep is usually the physical recovery
for your body well instead the ram is
the mental recovery Ram is when you are
dreaming REM is when your brain is
reassessing all the information that
collected during the day and it's
putting the information in the library
so you're developing memory and all that
kind of thing but the number one thing
that your body will always give priority
to is deep sleep because it's the
physical performance that your body
physically needs to recover first and
then your brain will record right so
it's likely important at all or is that
just a gateway to a deep in room the
reality is now that important is just
that your body is inefficient and you
end up with 50 of the time of sleep
being light sleep or awake okay and that
is why we have this hypothesis where we
can compress your sleep because we
believe we can make you more efficient
by helping you to fall asleep faster get
more deep sleep faster and we can
compress the amount of light sleeping a
lot that's okay so deep sleep and REM
sleep what is and I guess landscape in
these three stages what is happening to
the stats that help you figure out what
stage you're in so rhyme with the
easiest to detect because you're now
moving but your heart rate is
accelerated because you're probably
Dreaming or anyway you are in a certain
physical yeah and that's where if people
wake up they have sleep paralysis
because they're like oh [ __ ] I can't
move them what's going on except okay
because your brain deactivates the the
movement of the body because you are
dreaming otherwise you could start
walking or you could start moving your
arms but I even like dead still yeah so
on the sensors there's like no movement
yeah but the heart is accelerated okay
fine because something is happening and
you break it right so that is the
easiest then
um you have a deep sleep well instead
usually is when your heart rate goes to
the lowest point and so a certain type
of biometric like respiration is really
slow
um and heart rate is really slow and
usually if you're not moving you're not
completely still but obviously the
amount of movement of your body is uh
you're not tossing and turning
um instead light sleep your heart rate
and respiration have a different
behavior and after
then the best way to track your sleep
would be also to combine these
Biometrics with brain waves which is not
they tell you about your electrical
activity in your brain yeah but
customers don't want to wear a band
right so there were a couple of staff
that try to develop these bands to try
to be more accurate at this little
detection but the reality is they fail
because customers don't want to wear
this device are connected yeah okay so
gold standard would be with the with the
brainwave monitor which is what they do
in sleep studies yeah but like
realistically nobody else yeah but the
reality is all devices like ours will be
medical grade at heart rate and
cardiovascular diseases right so after
Adventure it will be medical grade and
respiration which means snowing yeah uh
you can be medical grade at temperature
and that is valuable because you can see
pregnancy obviously if you have fever
um hot flashes and things like that
sleep even if you go in a sleep clean
usually the average accuracy is around
80 percent so medical grade accuracy is
eighty percent
um and that can be achieved by devices
Like Us by combining all these different
metrics even if you don't have brain
waves nice bit of a random question
let's say someone's listening to this
they can't afford the eight Sleep
mattress and but they're a bit of a you
know I like computers like stuff how
hard is it to build a small mattress in
your bedroom like
what do you need 100 Max do it yeah
eight years ago Max would probably talk
more about that but it's the hardware is
probably not the like the hardest part
like putting together some sensors and
you know wheeze left on the very first
prototypes and we started the company we
moved to San Francisco for the first
year uh we used to have all the first
prototypes we were our office was an
apartment so in the bedroom where we
slept you know with all the first
prototypes and so you know someone could
put it together it's the algorithms
we've spent now so many years of the
company collecting that information
trainings algorithms working in
Partnerships with universities or with
companies that do medical grade devices
to actually feed that sort of gold
standard information into the training
of our algorithms and that just takes a
long time and it's really hard to do it
with this like contact with us right
sensors like that's not easy okay we
challenge anyone to do it yeah yeah I
think the big challenge is usually when
you want to start scaling right if you
want to build one device you can build
it probably atone it's very hard but you
can try the the biggest challenge they
had the last song that we had learned is
once you start moving thousands of units
per month uh getting a level of quality
that applies in the equivalent way to
all the units yeah that is really hard
yeah so I guess the first prototypes you
are having to get the Raspberry Pi with
some random ass sensors yeah you've got
this data what the hell does it mean
it's like maybe you growth in like okay
roughly but over time it becomes a more
sophisticated system and the other
challenge is like everything in life
right going from 0 to 80. we can do it
but the last 20 percent it's really
really high so in terms of accuracy
getting maybe to 70 80 percent you can
get there but get into 99 is really hard
and 80 accuracy is not that valuable
yeah not fair play Okay so we've got the
device we've got the sensors and we can
now tell with 99 certainty are we in
light sleep are we in deep Sleep are we
in REM sleep why why is that good like
what what action are we taking from that
in our specific case which is the main
difference compared to wearables is we
adjust temperature right because each
the each sleep stage needs a different
type of temperature as we were saying
deep should be called the ram it should
be warmer neutral and that is how we
give you up to 34 more deep sleep and up
to 32 percent that is equal so is it
like
liquid nitrogen going through the
mattress like what's what's going on in
Prototype V1 that you could make in in a
in your backyard you can use water uh
that is what we use so you need to build
the thermal engine the thermal engine
can heat and cool this water and so the
outgo is detecting the different stages
and based on the stage can automatically
adjust the temperature and warm you up
or cool you down yeah yes my
sister-in-law got a night sleep um
mattress as a birthday present a few
months ago and they came with a little
tank thing yeah
um and she just swears by it now and
she's like last night my brother
switched it off because I married um and
she was she was just a little bit she
was at work in the morning she was like
why did I sleep so badly and he was like
oh sorry I switched it off and she was
like oh my why did you switch it off so
she's our massive supporter of uh
amazing
um so okay so you figure out what state
if you're in
and then you modulate the temperature of
the bed accordingly and you I guess you
can see before and after and you can run
I suppose if you wanted to you could
randomize a group of people to not to do
that like one of the nights or something
and see what difference does it make
yeah yeah so we had
um several hundreds people uh where we
tracked their sleep Data before using
the Pod and after using the Pod okay and
what we saw was after the 34 more deep
sleep up to 32 percent but firstly
quality up to 19 recovery then there was
another interesting Discovery so we are
able to slow down your heart rate by up
to two heart beats per minute to give
you an idea that is the equivalent of
three months of in-test training and we
give it to you in the first week yeah
the other thing is we are able to
improve your HIV we are talking about
HRV to an equivalent of what your HIV
was 10 years earlier so we make your HIV
stats 10 years younger um
yeah it's just to be clear it's not that
we reinvented the wheels there is plenty
of medical evidence that proves that
camera regulation includes sleep so this
was already proven before they sleep and
it was just the first device to really
bring this to Consumer on a large scale
and making sure that people like you
like us like your sister can just get
better sleep
um heart rate variability so I was
interviewing someone yesterday who's a
neuroscientist who talks about like
performance and Leadership and stuff and
talked a lot about heart rate
variability as being like a marker of
stress
um what's what's going on there for
people that might not be familiar like
why why is it a marker of stress is a
market of physical stress not
governmental stress right if you're
stressed or not that is not going to be
reflective it can be directionally
reflected but the number one thing is
physical stress so the example I always
make is the one of the marathon right so
if you do a Marathon today tomorrow will
be reflected in your HIV and your HIV
will be worse than what it usually is
okay but instead if you are fully rested
your HIV will go up and app usually is a
positive sign for HIV
okay so you want a low heart rate but a
high heart rate variability because
that's yeah because that shows that your
heart rate is more reactive to the
things that you're doing which shows
that you have just more interesting like
your boxer analogy being a bit more
reactive yeah correct and so however is
is that a stat that changes throughout
the day the heart rate variability or is
it like it changes during the day okay
any changes during the night okay so
also a way to look at that is to look at
the Delta of what your HIV was in the
first deep sleep yeah and in the last
deep sleep and that is the epoxy of
recording
but the bottom line is yeah it changes
during the day and during the night okay
and so if it's high during the day that
means in the morning when you want to
measure it is when you wake up okay what
is the most important and the higher the
better
the higher the better when you wake up
and you and the eight State mattress
does that because it tells you what it
was just before you woke up yeah imagine
that it's like a tank of energy yeah
this is just an analogy right from a
medical standpoint it's not like that
but imagine that it's a pack of energy
and you know the higher the Baton
because it's full the lower and the
worse because it's empty if you have a
marathon the previous day you'll be
empty okay now an important thing a lot
of people that we see especially on
Twitter are Community shares or stats is
they say well you have a really hard HRV
but then my HRV is not there it's like
it varies with age right so there's sort
of different ranges that are considered
to be like healthy versus if you're like
an athlete like athletes tend to have it
higher but also it's important to build
your personal Baseline yeah it's very
personal yeah it's very personal and you
want to compare it to your own Baseline
and how it Trends over time we cannot
compare mine and yours yeah well instead
for HR and offer heart rate address you
can more or less do it for me HIV is
completely personal you need the
Baseline and then it's above or below
your Baseline okay okay is there
anything we can do like during the day
to affect our heart rate variability or
so okay so it's heart rate variability
more like a lagging indicator or if if
you were to just change it magically
would it actually make you feel better
in any any kind of way you can actually
imagine that there's a proxy for how for
Recovery how recovery is your body so
the way you can increase it is by
resting today and tomorrow will very
likely be higher yeah
um it's proven that through meditation
you can help HIV as well so it's really
a rest and Recovery and the other thing
you want to pay attention is if you're
training a lot you want to measure it
because if it's too low it's when you my
risk injuries because the tank is low
and that means you're less recovered and
so you need a bit more rest to be over
training yeah but there is a bit of a
lag like if you if you begin doing
training especially the types of
training was describing earlier with
like content General training like
strength training you should start
seeing an improvement in your HRV over
time it's like your body really is
becoming that more reactive you're
becoming more athletic physically in
their body and so there is some lag in
some of these influential factors into
your hrb nice
this is a bit of a bit of a lot of
potentially um sympathetic and
parasympathetic nervous system how does
that tie into this sort of stuff if at
all
yeah they're connected and they're
connected in the way you sleep but even
those are super personal and they can
change over time
um but they are also connected to
methods like HRV and HR yeah so this is
what I was talking to you about with
this neuroscientist yesterday she was
she was saying that a lot of people who
are in high stress jobs like Traders and
things will will be in sort of stress
mode High sympathetic activation for
most of the day and then they get home
you know then and they're even more
stressed because they haven't spent
enough time with the kids and all that
kind of stuff and you can see that
reflected in a high heart rate and
presumably a low heart rate variability
because now exactly they're in like kind
of cortisol and blood pressure mode yeah
which is where it sleep helps you right
because we can reduce your heart rate as
I was saying by up to two heart beats
per minute and we can increase your HIV
taking you 10 years younger so
temperature is an intervention to
potentially get you from that like five
or flight to the state where your body
says okay now I'm in a protected space I
can rest yeah 10 can have that effect
and sort of like when you think very
basically right evolutionary we used to
sleep outdoors and caves and temperature
was such a big indicator of our ability
to like is there fire animals are going
to stay away I'm going to be protected
what's that heat like right and so it's
just like so fascinating how our bodies
have evolved to use temperature in light
as just an indicator of looking up if
I'm protected I can fall asleep I can
press I can go into that remember I'm
not moving versus no I'm not protected I
need to stay
tits
it's really hard to be able to do it
because unless probably you're gonna
have but if you want to improve your
sleep quality and other ways to do a
salmon a cold plunge a sound like
and so this thermal shock yeah helps you
relax and fall asleep faster and get
back to sleep and the reason so Peter
latia talks about that as well and there
is plenty of evidence the reason why I'm
mentioning this is thermal shocks so
playing with your body temperature is
proven in different degrees you have a
massive impact on your systems and its
good quality so if you are in a hotel or
they have a sauna and a cold plunge you
should try to do that and you will sleep
like a baby if you use a dry bath right
if you do bath in a cold shower so to an
extent that can be helpful yeah nice uh
okay so I have been talking to a few
people about about exape and they look
at the website and they look at the
price tag and then they think oh my God
like
that it's completely non-starter
um but also In fairness people would
have left the price tag for the Tesla
Roadster and what the [ __ ] uh how do you
guys think about pricing it's a very
premium product that most people can't
afford and yet presumably your impact
your the mission is to help more people
yeah what's going on there I have two
answers yeah and I started from the
consumer answer and then why we are
Priceline here like that so if you
finance our product I think is around 60
bucks a month that is two bucks per
night it's less than a coffee so if you
care about your sleep and you assume
that what we are telling you is true
that will improve your sleep which is
true are you gonna pay two bucks a night
to get better sleep and improve your
health and improve your daily
performance that that is the question I
would maybe then
the reason why it's priced like that is
because uh the the type of technology
that we use is really advanced and for
the time being it's still expensive it's
not that we are having any different
margin from what an average company
would have so we're just running a
business and we need to be able to you
know sustain the business so we can keep
evolving that as you were saying we
always make reference to Tesla our
largest investor was the first investor
in Tesla so this is our Roadster price
will go down over time but at the end of
the day you're using one of the most
sophisticated Technologies on Earth and
for now uh the only way to run a
business is to run it at that price
um what's the what does the roadmap look
like if you can share some details there
um there will be more than I asked going
back to their personal analogy
um over time the price will become more
and more affordable right we want to
democratize health and sleep
um but then there are another bunch of
products that we're working on some of
them still focus on thermal regulation
because there is plenty of medical
evidence that it helps but the end goal
is a device where Alexander and I were
already sleeping in where we control
light and noise in the future will
control oxygen air quality and air
temperature and we will do a full body
scanning every single night so expecting
three to five years from now to do a
substantial MRI every single day nice
and potentially detect things like
cancer kidney stones and cysts sick how
do I get on the beta tester list
everyone wants that it's co-founders
um but one of the things that I read was
that you had some difficulties building
the company initially and both of you
being I guess quite foreigners in
America what was that experience like in
the early days yeah so I mean first I I
none of us graduated from the big ivy
league uh universities in in the US
um in my case I also had this real
background as a business lawyer and I
was coming from a different industry so
any I would say credibility I had built
before it was not really applying to
Silicon Valley because I didn't know
anyone in Silicon Valley and I think was
very similar for you and so I think it's
just part of the game right in Silicon
Valley a lot is about reputation and
trust people are giving you money
because they believe that you're a great
founder and you can make something
happen that no one else could build yeah
and so they always try the best
investors to find data points about you
what they do in a positive way right and
so usually going at the notice certain
universities are talking to other people
that know you is really important in the
valley and we didn't have that at the
beginning but then I think over time we
built hopefully that reputation through
y combinator then causal Avengers
investing with and then Founder's fine
right so one little step at a time
I I I think now we probably producers
but yeah I think it's so incredible and
we hear often you know Matteo being from
Middle East is also from Italy and he's
actually he dropped out of school in
Italy started building businesses pretty
early on which is is a rarity I think in
in Europe in general for people who drop
out of college and he did it and so none
of us had any of that so that pattern
matching the toes describing but then
it's incredible to think that it may
have taken us a little longer but once
we launched our crowdfinder campaign in
2015 who
um actually we that was available
internationally so there may be some
people listening to this who've got our
very very first product
um once we launched that that campaign
was really successful it quickly made
over a million dollars in sales and
ended up costing close to 2 million
pre-orders then that was that pattern
that people needed to see to say well
these people were building this thing
that maybe we didn't think they could
deliver actually our building something
people want and that's when things
really started changing for us and it's
incredible that there's still that
opportunity and especially we see it in
Silicon Valley where trust can be built
through that hard work and through
actually proving that you are building
something people want to pay for and you
can kind of get into the network that
you're looking to get into just through
that one
okay yeah that makes a lot of sense and
we ended up then raising 160 million
over time right from
most of the best investors in the valley
yeah and so I think coming from Italy
and coming from Europe that was uh one
of the most
um impressive things I have learned
about the US where if you work hard and
if you prove yourself then the
opportunity will come so yeah maybe the
first years we had some challenges out
there didn't but then at the end of the
day the opportunity was still there and
we we have proven it which means that
anyone else can have access to the same
um any advice for budding entrepreneurs
that love kind of the story they're like
oh yeah that sounds sick you you take an
idea you literally invent a thing and
then it's worth 500 million dollars like
any any top tips for for people who want
to want to get into the entrepreneurship
thing
um I mean keep going keep building right
that is what I always say that now is
running a company is like at roller
coasters or apps and downs and you
should then fool yourself when
throughout the app but you shouldn't be
depressed when there are the Downs right
at the end of the day you need to just
find the medium and the average and
stick with that what sort of towns have
you guys had
um every down you can think of
multiple times not even a single time
but you go particularly with Hardware
right there was a big hype at the
beginning then there was a time where a
lot of other companies failed so it was
really really hard to raise money unless
you were having incredible metrics we
were able to raise that money at the
time but again particularly when you
raise money you should always think that
you misunder the investors 99 will say
no and one is going to say yes and so if
you just think mentally getting 99 knows
is tough because you have a dream you
have a vision you believe in that you
know how hard your team is working and
how great they are and just being not
hit in the face punching the face with
no no no and at the end of the day it
sounds like is it's not about you from
the investors but it's something like
saying look you know this could be a
good business my baby is not going to be
a billion dollar business but you just
need one yes so just keep going
what other uh Downs have you had to make
uh maybe outside the realm of
fundraising I think I would say probably
that after building the first product
right like when you're early on and the
reason why Capital Metro is talking a
lot about Investors is so important is
because we are innovating so there's a
lot of like our indeed investment in
building the product but the ultimate
proxy successful business is whether
people are buying it and how much are
they willing to pay for it right so
that's where you keep a lot of your
focus on the day-to-day but in in those
in the early stages that first year we
did a crowdfunding campaign and we put
out the concept we have to build pretty
touch with this product and we have
shown it to a lot of people we put it
out there and there's like all these
people who want to buy it and now we're
like well we have to build this product
and we went through y combinator we had
this amazing opportunity after getting
reductor toys to get in right so again
the No No No and then he finally get a
yes
um and after we finish the right
combinator they said well now you need
to go and like build these products and
Mateo and Max moved to China to build
the team there to actually manufacture
these products and you know those those
months are really hard because even
though maybe now you raise money um no
money is not the angle you need they'll
turn you stupid and willing to love it
and there needs to be more people buying
it and so there were a lot of challenges
to figure it out there it was completely
new space for us none of us have built
Hardware products before then you get
that product and you need to ship it and
then maybe you start seeing your shoes
or maybe it's not the product that you
ultimately want to build because we
discovered very early on when we built
that product is that that product was
tracking your data but it didn't have
the cooling functionality which was key
to do full thermal regulation and that
was the number one request that those
early backers of the company that built
that funded us with our crop funding
campaign requested right they said give
us cooling give us Cooling and so in the
back of your mind as an entrepreneur you
say well I don't have that yet and I
don't have the money to build it and I
don't have the team to build it right
and so it was sort of the throw of
Sorrows that why commentator talks about
is like you're going through this period
of time it was really really hard and
you want to get to the next Milestone
you want to prove that then you can
raise Capital to then build the product
that now you know people really want to
send that stuff yeah
it seems like Hardware is just super
tough yeah like especially when you're
like
you and Max move to China like wow
what's the story there yeah so the story
is I go to her and I say look things are
not happening in manufacturing I need to
go to China and so she says oh cool when
are you gonna go and I say tomorrow did
you say oh cool and when I back and I
say once I fix it and so I came back
three four months later right
um after so were you trying to remotely
manufacture from Factory to China in
Italy yeah we had another person who was
there
but he needed some help there to make
sure we could accelerate things and so I
just moved I just moved there we rented
an apartment in Shenzhen yeah and we
lived there so actually it was a great
experience for me right now I can look
back to say like I live for some time in
China yeah but it's really hard for a
couple of reasons first you need a lot
of capital yeah right both to develop it
second is really slow compared to
software software you can release the
feature and yeah right that thing
usually if you're really fast you can
release a new product every year the
average company needs 18 to 24 months to
release a new Avatar you need more
departments because you need obviously
people for supply chain people for
quality people for manufacturing all the
logistic one inside the software company
doesn't have that cost so even the fixed
cost of personnel on our employees is
way higher and more than anything you
need to be able to forecast demand
because right from now the holidays is
coming how much are we going to sell you
need to build that unit if you're under
build then you don't sell into a build
then you have these in control in your
balance sheet and so the complexity of
the business is is very different as the
CEO is exciting but at the same time is
also the month it's very rewarding
because then people do use it at home
yeah and that is I think something
fascinating we talk about this a lot
because Hardware is really hard has the
word heart in it it's like it really is
really complex but it's fascinating when
you go to a restaurant we were there a
few months ago in San Francisco to
restaurant with part of our team and
some of us were wearing swag from the
company we have the logo and the waiter
who was um serving our table said oh I
see you all work at eight sleep and said
I have a pod and I love it and it's just
so incredible and it happens to us often
we have people on the team who are
boarding a plane in an airport and be
like oh you work any sleep and so it's
just really cool to think that you go
through all the hardships which I think
any kind of business goes to even a
small business right even
non-venture-backed but then you're
building something in our case that
helps people sleep better live healthier
it's like the physical product they get
to use it every day and I think it's
part of what keeps us here is such a
unique Journey
that's really cool like I where
um kind of dabbling with working with a
company to try and make some Hardware
stuff now
um like productivity accessories and
like trying to manufacture our own
mechanical keyboard for computer
it's something about physical product
that seems really cool because it's like
always with you yeah in a way that
software is even though software is way
easier
um that's pretty cool um
so team would have grown from the three
of you to now 100 plus what were the the
challenges and I guess
um scaling up the the team over time
um challenges is always at the end of
the day culture meaning when you build a
company it's like you cannot be friend
with everyone right you have your own
culture you have your own attitude I
come from sport so I'm you know we call
our culture demanding and supportive I'm
really demanding in expectations then if
things don't go as planned I would be
supportive and I will have your back but
I expect you to give 100 right and so
you need to find people that you know
share the same values not because they
are right or wrong but because this is
how we are as a Founders and as a
founding team
um and so in the early days probably we
made also a bunch of mistakes in hiring
no we never hired bad people but maybe
they were not the type of people that
were the perfect scene I think now we
became way better than that in the past
two years the the quality of people that
we have hired is extremely impressive if
we if you guys think of like you know
your the like okay so in in every
company there are some people in your
team that you think if I could clone you
100 times over I would press that button
a zillion times what are the
characteristics of those sorts of people
and I'm asking because someone listening
to this has probably got a normal job
and they probably want to be an a player
in their normal job but they might not
know like what what does an a player
actually look like so so for you in in a
sleep like what are the things that make
someone just absolute rock star of where
you're just like I want to clone this
person a million times over there's one
indicator we talked about this like last
week that I told you I identified this
applies for people who start with us
when they're a little bit earlier in
their career because then executives are
different and you can talk about that
which is really fascinating but for
people who are earlier in their career
what you notice in in what we have seen
at eight sleep is that
every six to 12 months this person is
different
because their rate of growth and
learning is so Steep and they're just
changing they're becoming better at a
rate that is just outpacing anyone else
and so when we look at these people you
know you have these sort of cohort of
employees that may be doing the same
year you say wow this person right here
is completely different they just mature
they've changed this other person hasn't
they're not growing at the same way and
that to me has become like the quickest
way to see how there's like a real rock
star versus just someone putting really
great and solid and 80 20 is usually
they care they have high intensity they
have velocity and they grow but we have
five elements that I measure probably on
exactly the first one is what is called
clavicle thinking so the quality of
setting the priorities and the order
yeah which you will attach it right so
what to do and in what order quite good
thank you yeah the second is what I call
menagerial efficiency so the ability to
do less to do more with less if you
think what we are doing well we are in
Revenue no more than nine digits uh
brand rate being 100 people in other is
very small we are really really
efficient and that is reflected in our
bottom line and then how much we burn
the left so managerial efficiency the
third is velocity I'm obsessed with
velocity if you tell me that something
takes you a month I will ask you to
break it down in 30 pieces okay what can
you do tomorrow yeah
um the last one is the obsession for
talent we really believe in the quality
of talent finding the talent and
developing them and the last one is bad
Razer which is this concept of growth
what are you doing today you are not
doing last quarter why how can you give
me data points measurable data points
that you are better at something and if
you're an executive I want to see the
same in your team so who is doing
something they were now doing before how
did you grow them
um
what are some things that you guys have
learned over time have you evolved as
leaders and as executives are asking
very selfishly because now I'm managing
Team 13 people and I've always just like
[ __ ] I feel like I'm about this yeah for
me it was really a journey because I
mean when we started the company I was
pretty young and I had never really
managed people so Mattel is a testament
to is a a witness to my process there
it's a very I would say emotional
journey and if you don't learn to sort
of understand the emotions that drive
you in the decisions in your analysis of
your team in the day-to-day what
motivates you what gives you energy what
doesn't and to tame and manage your
emotions
um you can't really grow as a leader
um and I think that was something you
know material is to see other companies
so he has my manager I report to him
that we've worked a lot on together and
so it really is an emotional Journey
more than you think it's just being
productive and working and working more
um and then the second thing that I
really learned in that journey is all
about the people when you to hire the
right people when you're able to attract
the right people to your team you can
make a huge difference as a leader if
you don't have the right people you
can't you know the coastline is one of
our investors says the team he builds
the company you build at the end of the
day so that is really key but then in my
case and I think for anyone listening
who is maybe not experiencing what
they're about to set themselves to do or
very young you can also you have to
complement yourself with people that
maybe don't even work for you but there
are like advisors or mentors outside and
that's been really valuable for me learn
from other people who have done what
you're looking to do and you have to
learn really fast you need to be able to
go to into those conversations very
humbly and ask a lot of questions and
then bring that knowledge back into your
own practice as a leader
the reason emotional trait that is
really at the end of the day to
an era when I was talking at the
beginning is you you always second guess
yourself sometimes seeing okay how you
approach these and what is our culture
and then goes back to what I was saying
earlier you need to know who you are and
you need to build the company around
that because again it's like friendship
you cannot be friend with someone who
doesn't share your own value you can
force yourself but it's not gonna last
and so at the end of the day you need to
understand okay what really matters for
me it goes back to this concept of our
culture of being demanding and
supportive you think like a sports team
you're not a family sometimes in the
early days of family we're not right
there is a match here yeah and top
performance needs to be rewarded more
than anyone else we are in the playoffs
and we want to win the title the
championship and so that is that the
intensity that is required we work hard
extremely hard we value velocity
and this is how you will always you know
what what you should expect which
doesn't mean is universally good
just be aware before you join us because
then if there is not a match you will
not be happy
and we're not going to compromise on
some of the things right so probably
this world compromised before or maybe I
should compromise here maybe no I
shouldn't push for that yeah instead no
velocity is key for us I will always
push you to get things done in half the
time yeah
how do you balance the striving for to
achieve the big goal in the big mission
and the metrics and stuff versus
enjoying the present moment and enjoying
the ride as you're as you're going
through
so that is not my strength
they coach me and they give me advice
um I think everyone is different right
and it's also based on your age the
state of your career what you're doing
but at the end of the day the key thing
is to working on
a project that you believe matters and
so there is always these distinction
sometimes in the starter World between
missionaries and mercenaries and
definitely if you talk to our people
they are missionaries right we have a
vision where we want to get to
potentially detect cancer we want to
save lives we want to help the people
live a longer of their life and so that
is very from a motivational standpoint
is is massive for a lot of people
compared to going to a company where you
sell ads and you just monetize right you
know uh selling cook ads on the digital
platform here we are really helping
millions of people uh to live a better
life or save their life
and so that's what I think is the number
one driver and also the reason why a lot
of people at our company they have been
with us for so long even if he is such
an intense place right because it
becomes hard to find another company
where you as an engineer an ml engineer
you're saving lives and there are a lot
of ml jobs
but if you're working on the cart for an
e-commerce startup just to convert more
purchases it's not the people interested
in your life yeah yeah I think on the
enjoyment on daily
um yeah it's something that I think the
way we compensate that is that we are
different as Founders and I think that's
why also a lot of people say well it's
great when you have a partner in
business because you try to seek like
that complimentary conversations right
where how do you remind each other of
sort of the journey you've been through
and like what you still have to achieve
and there's a balance like Mateo's
definitely is a CEO and the vision
setting person in the company the one
that's always pushing us forward like
pushing people to achieve more and then
maybe I play a role if they're like hey
look at look at this and like look at
what we've done but for eight sleep I
think for companies that are really
selling amazing products to Consumers
the best way to remind yourself of the
journey is every day when you wake up
and you see in our case we see a lot of
this on Twitter people talking about how
much you love your product because you
know maybe last today you have like a
terrible day or you know you lost a
candidate you wanted to hire or today
you're about to have like a really
complicated day but when you wake up and
you see that that reminds you of why
you're about to go through that day
um funny thing I wanted to ask is that
um what's the
score what's the dynamic between you
guys you're married you're running a
company a lot of people say that you
shouldn't go into business with your
spouse but you guys have been doing this
for eight years like what are the what
are the secrets what have you learned
yeah a couple of Tricks uh and it was uh
mainly because uh of Alex that she has
set some boundaries because otherwise in
my case I can just keep talking about
work yeah whatever because I'm
passionate about that but
um so firstly we use WhatsApp for
personal staff and we use slack for
business right and so sometimes I might
be on slack asking for something to be
done faster and or to raise the bar and
in the meanwhile and what's stopping her
saying oh what do we have for dinner
tonight yeah but then the other rules
she has said is that after a certain
time like call it 9 30 PM I cannot talk
about work because our point is you need
to treat me like you would treat any
other colleague and it's not that you
call them at 10 pm unless it's really
really urgent and I say fine but I can
still slacker yeah
[Music]
and I know it's me but I cannot talk
about the topic
or um
sometimes we're having Zoom calls and we
are just in a room next to each other
but we are both on Zoom for example The
Shield opposed to me and we do a
one-on-one at least once a week
sometimes also on Saturday but my trip
was tough Joy is the one-on-one and the
Chipmunk stuff is in New York we are in
Miami and so we do her one-on-one
remotely even if she's like in the other
room yeah
um so I think if you need to
professionalize the working relationship
you can't treat each other as oh
um you know we're just family and most
important for us because this is not a
family business you know we've been
together for longer than we've done the
company but this is not a family
business we have business partners we
have investors I'm an executive in the
company he's an executive in the company
we can be five from our jobs we can be
replaced right and we need to earn our
spot even though we're Founders you need
to earn your spot you need to grow you
need to be able to manage and so I think
professionalizing is like step number
one and that has made things easier and
so what that means also is that if you
have a discussion of professional
setting you can't bring it personal and
vice versa
um and the other big thing that we have
learned I think this applies to any
working relationship regardless of
whether you're related or married or not
is that you need to understand how you
are different in the approach that you
have to very key things and one of them
for us is how do we solve problems or
gain Clarity Mateo and I are very
different in that sense and so he has I
think probably part of your uh lawyer
trained brain like he has this amazing
capacity to focus and he can really
focus on one specific thing and subject
for a very long time and keep for hours
thinking about it thinking about it
until he finds the solution and his
brain performs really well at that level
for me it's very different my brain sort
of like has the more like maybe creative
side and so I get my best ideas when I'm
not purposefully trying to solve that
problem I sort of go outside of that
world and then suddenly things just
click I'm a big dreamer for example
connecting to sleep I dream every night
and my brain sort of putting together
all of these things during my sleep and
then sometimes I wake up and I'm like
okay now I feel Clarity and so finding
these things over the years have helped
us because then I when I tell him hey I
cannot talk about work anymore today
it's Saturday give me my day he
understands that as long as I'm being
lazy right as a Founder you're always on
but my brain needs it and then anybody
come back to you later and suddenly I
have the solution for what we're talking
about right
um one thing I want to ask is uh any
books that you guys would recommend that
have changed um your thinking or
impacted your life or business in any
way there's two and actually gifted them
to everyone in my team
um that I always kind of go back to one
is shoe dog by Phil Knight and you know
my team takes several marketing and
brand and building Aid sleep as that
iconic company is a really important
part of what we do day in and day out
and I think Nike is a great example of a
company that has done that and the other
one is the scorecake syrup itself you
focus on the fundamentals and like the
most basic inputs of how you're
structuring your business and how every
single person in your team is doing
their job you should be able to win the
Championships that book is uh from all
of the the Frameworks built by Bill
Walsh um and this he was this incredible
coach of the 49ers I was able to take a
team that was like struggling into
winning multiple championships
there is a high output management which
is highly recommended for any manager it
was the former CEO of Intel it's really
like the Bible for for management uh
there is if you're in another build from
the former CEO of the nest there is the
almanac of Nevada Nevada who is also one
of our investors
and if you already have a bit more
philosophical there is meditations from
Marcus aurangis which is really cool to
see how people were thinking 2000 years
ago and those that thinking still
applies to us today amazing guys thank
you so much this has been absolutely
wonderful um so great having you here
thank you for all the insights on all of
the optimizing sleep diet nutrition
exercise all of those things definitely
I'm going to take away the 6 PM social
event thing because this is no reason
not to try and trying to do some
interval training as well and yeah I've
got I've got my king size Aid sleep in a
box at home and I will install it in my
new place like next week so I'll report
back and let you know how I guess thank
you thanks so much for coming
all right so that's it for this week's
episode of Deep dive thank you so much
for watching or listening all the links
and resources that we mentioned in the
podcast are going to be linked down in
the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you're listening
to this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye